hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the whisper
challenge we're here with Mathias Wade
and Jesse Jesse's my good friend just
like Tyler was here which friend was
better we'll see how it is after the end
of the video so we're gonna be doing the
whisper challenge once more if you don't
know how the game is played here's a
synopsis of what happens cuz I can't
explain right the whisper towns where
the other three participants are
listening to very loud music and can't
hear what I'm saying so I read the tweet
and then whisper it very quietly to them
they try to read my lips and interpret
what I'm saying and then pass that along
to the next person like a game of
telephone
obviously hilarity ensues afterwards so
there you go
so we're gonna play it we're gonna read
the tweets we already sent out the
tweets right now and we're gonna get
started almost immediately exactly now
Wade's big butt is bouncy bouncy can I
do it one more time Wade's big butt is
bouncy bouncy white people's hearts are
bouncy bouncy okay white people's [ __ ]
white people's [ __ ] bounce on my dick
okay I think I got it white people just
can't punch me in the dick that's what
his lips told me he had penis in there
but you put it at the end and he said at
the beginning oh wait what did you say
you gotta remember the head together
play it back what he said people's [ __ ]
bumps on my dude wasn't that Valerius
haha well I said something about white
people's hearts and bouncy bouncing yeah
which was close lose it
Wade's big butt is so bouncy bouncy I
got badly
I like pizza with soda and cheese I like
face my face and blaster with cheese
okay I like to pinch my face with
plastic cheese I like to punch my face
with plastic sheets I like pizza with
soda and cheese can you feel the love
tonight
Mufasa can you feel the love tonight
Mufasa okay I have no idea what you said
but okay would you please feel the
lipstick on my face would you please fix
the burrito on my face okay I heard two
things the first thing that I heard was
would you wishy-washy there's a printer
on my face please switch the burrito on
my face is what I say oh I got faith I
did would you please feel the lipstick
on my face oh please tell me you had
face in there no yeah was there would
you please at the beginning no can you
feel the love tonight Mufasa okay Ducks
are chicks and alcohol never mixes
that's so not true I think I'm so wrong
I should have watched one more time
Oh No soldier ships Oh baby fetuses
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't jizz on my puppies please soldier
shits Oh baby
so the actual one was ducks are
bloodthirsty little beasts oh my god you
have lovely skin I can't wait to try it
on okay pretty sure this isn't it but it
sounded and looked exactly like what he
said you have a lovely kidney I can't
wait to put it in me I'm saying this you
you have the biggest thing can't wait to
jump on you so what I heard you have the
biggest dick sister princess ever pulled
[Applause]
and I said you
oh you have a good kidney I can't wait
to put it in media and the real one was
you have lovely skin I can't wait to try
it on
oh so mine wasn't that like no no you
were you were fairly good you body parts
and tell ya this is imminent put a dick
into it like I am building an army of
potatoes to kill evil apples was that
one I please the king of hamsters
because I am a royal hamster um okay I
bleed apple juice because I stepped on
your little hamster I bleed Heppell
juice oh because it was super delicious
you said I bleed apple juice because I
stepped on your little hamster what I
actually said was I am building an army
of potatoes to kill evil apples so how
it came full circle
we got apples and then you brought back
I don't know there's no way that that
turned back it down thanks so much for
watching the second once again please
vote Jesse off or let us know if you
want him to stay but overall Mathias
challenges another challenge that we
just did where they both die I don't cuz
I'm awesome
but thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the first wither for
challenge and other videos that we've
done together with a skinned knee as
always we'll see you in the next one bye
bye
[Music]